>>Daniel : This book gave me the biggest ah-ha
experience I had since I first came across
marginal utility which is saying a lot.
I think you'll find the ideas in this book
very provocative. They're quite a, quite different
from what passes for economic wisdom out of
Washington. You know the discussions about
which group of irresponsible, which irresponsible
institution is going to be able to get its
money from the public trough to continuing
surviving; quite different from free markets.
Maybe it's time to let the quit, let the quit,
biggest bank robbers in history quit running
institutions that they've wrecked.
Please join me in welcoming John.
[applause]
>>John D. Medaille: Thank you, Daniel.
I'd like to say how happy I am to be here
at the Google Headquarters. This is always,
it's the second time I've been here, it's
always exciting for me. I just love this place.
I'd like to thank Daniel for inviting me and
y'all for coming.
The, I have to say that this is a new experience
for me because when I speak I normally take
out my speech and flat-footed I give the speech.
But I, since I've come to the epicenter of
technology here I decided to do a PowerPoint
presentation; actually an OpenOffice IMPRESS
presentation because --
[applause]
we don't wanna send our money to the wrong
places. But also I like to keep up with technology
at least within a 20 year window.
[laughter]
But today I'm here to talk about my book,
Toward a Truly Free Market, a Distributist
Perspective.
Of course first time I'm using technology
of course naturally it runs into a big problem.
The machine freezes up just as we plug it
in but of course at the center of technology
we can fix those things.
Well then today I'd like to talk about three
questions.
The first is what is a free market?
And the second is what is distributism?
And finally, what can we do about our current
problems?
Now what is a free market?
There's something very surprising about this.
If you go through standard economic textbooks
you'll find that they're not actually defined.
They just sort of assume that everybody knows
what that means.
There is, however, a kind of implied definition.
And that implied definition is, "A free market
is one that's free from government regulation."
But the odd thing about this definition is
that it's a negative definition. Alright,
it doesn't really tell you what it is. It
indicates the absence of something not the
presence of something.
Now it does allow for function of government
and the sole function of government would
be to protect private property.
So this indicates that if left to itself the
market will take care of itself and it needs
nothing else outside of its own internal laws.
Let's test that definition.
Let's look at this sterling gentleman: Jay
Gould. Jay Gould was a businessman during
the days of the robber barons, the 19th century,
and Mr. Gould controlled all of the railroads
that went into New York City. And he decided
to use this control of the railroads to establish
for himself a monopoly in building supplies.
And how did he do this?
He refused to let his railroad carry any competitive
products.
[pause]
If you were a man-manufacturer of building
supplies you couldn't put 'em on Jay Gould's
railroad which means you couldn't get 'em
to the City of New York.
Now this ended with the imposition when Congress
im-imposed the common carrier rule on railroads.
Common carrier rule means that if you offer
to carry freight you must carry all freight
on an equal basis and not discriminate against
anybody.
So question: where is freedom in this case?
[pause]
Does it lie with unrestricted private property?
Under that system the-the owner can say, let's
say you're a-a producer of Pennsylvania blue
stone, Jay Gould can say to you, "I will not
carry your products unless you first sell
them to me at a price and quantity that I
dictate."
[pause]
Or is freedom with the common carrier rule
which states that you must carry all freight
that's presented to you?
From Mr. Gould's standpoint, well unrestricted
private property equals the freedom of the
market.
[pause]
But from the producers standpoint it equals
tyranny. It equals somebody else telling him
what he has to make, how much he has to make,
and what he's gonna make.
[pause]
And for buyers and sellers in the market clearly
the common carrier rule equals market freedom
and without that common carrier rule there
is no market freedom. There's just a bunch
corporate warlords.
[pause]
So before we can understand the free market
we have to understand freedom.
And what is freedom?
It's the rule of reason. In other words, freedom
has an object. It's not license. It's not
just the absence of any restraint it's actually
directed toward reason.
And markets are in fact made by rules. Without
rules, without limits, the invisible hand
of the market becomes the visible fist crushing
all opposition as in the case of Jay Gould.
In fact all human relationships are rule bound.
[pause]
Make an analogy to the Internet. Somebody's
not following the protocols, the whole thing
locks up. In order to have the freedom of
the Internet you have to have a set of rules.
And so, or else this whole marvelous structure
falls apart.
Think about a football game. If there's not
a regulator whom we call the referee out there
to throw the yellow fag-flag when somebody
grabs a face mask, nobody's gonna step on
the field; the mortality rates would simply
be too high.
[pause]
But rules can be reasonable or oppressive
and so rules themselves need a rule.
So what makes a rule reasonable?
Well within the economic realm, economic reason
equals justice. Justice means each person
gets what is due to them.
Now there's two forms of justice.
The first is justice in exchange, which we
call commutative or corrective justice. And
the second is justice in production, which
we call distributive justice.
Let's deal with commutative justice.
Commutative justice deals with a change of
ownership in existing things. So when you
buy-buy bread for money you're changing the
ownership of two already existing things.
And justice in that case consists in equality
and exchange.
So we presume that A and B after the exchange
have an equal amount just in different forms.
If bread is a dollar, a loaf of bread is a
dollar is, after the exchange, the seller
has a dollar and you have the loaf of bread,
but in terms of-of wealth you both have the
same amount.
[pause]
Now in a free commodity market we generally
assume that that is, that equality is expressed
by the price. This is also called arithmetic
ju-justice because it can in principle be
calculated.
[coughs]
We should note, however, that market pricing
doesn't work in monopolistic, oligopolistic,
or controlled markets. The price may not,
may not be reflective of the true value.
Let's go to distributive justice, though.
The fist applies to the production of new
things; where commutative justice cannot solve
the problems of distribution.
So when we a take a tree and make some chairs,
we've called something new into-into being;
something that wasn't there before. Alright?
[pause]
How do we distribute these new things? Who
gets them?
Well the rule of justice here is based on
contribution to prod, to the production, quite
obviously. Those who contributed to the production
of the new chairs ought to get a fair share
of the new chairs. And also nobody else, people
who did not contribute to the production ought
not to have a claim on that production.
[pause]
But we also have to take into account the
merit of the contribution. So some person's
a carpenter and another person's the janitor.
Now we evaluate those contributions differently;
that's the merit of the contribution.
Think about merit of the contribution though.
Is they cannot be calculated even in principle.
You have to make a judgment.
[pause]
Now Aristotle pointed out that this judgment
on the relative merit of contributions will
vary from culture to culture. So how do we
value the different inputs to a product from
the product engineer, yes sir.
>>male in audience #1: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: No that's the contribution's
production. That is a contribution of production.
Of course, you have to understand the owner
of the tree, the tree is made available only
by labor. The tree in the forest isn't very
useful to anybody, it has to be cut down,
it has to be transported, etcetera.
Okay.
The, so in evaluating the various roles: engineer,
marketing, the janitor, the production line
worker, etcetera, Aristotle pointed out that
aristocratic societies will evaluate those
contributions one way, oligarchic societies
another-another way, demo-democratic societies
another way.
But the point there is that you really don't
have a calculation; you have a cultural judgment.
Alright, skip forward to our own cultural
moment: the current problem.
We are obviously in the midst of some very
difficult times; more difficult for some of
us than for others.
But it is worth noting that 90% of all economists
missed the coming of this disaster and those
who pointed out what was coming were marginalized
and ridiculed.; called "Dr. Doom" and "Cassandras."
>>male in audience #2: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Oh I think it's pretty
accepted but actually 90% is a very optimistic
rating, because there weren't a handful of
economists and I've seen surveys of the literature
that make the 90% number, in fact, very optimistic.
Okay.
But the same was true of the last disaster
and the one before that, and the one before
that, and [whispering] and the one before
that, and the one before that, and the one
before that.
The truth is if your doctor had the same track
record as your economist you'd be dead by
now. Something is missing in economic science.
It is an incomplete science.
In its present state it cannot actually describe
the workings of any actual economy, hence,
it cannot be predictive. You can't predict
a course of-of a system that you can't describe.
And finally, it is not prescriptive; if you
cannot prescribe a rem, a remedy if you cannot
predict the course of the disease.
So what is missing?
[pause]
From Aristotle to Adam Smith economics was
a colony of ethics. And no philosopher or
theologian worth his stipend was without his
political and economic commentary.
But it was always a political economy. It
always embedded in a system of laws, of customs,
of political institutions, of social expectations.
And nobody ever looked at it apart from these
things.
[pause]
But the 19th century political economists
were embarrassed by this connection with justice.
Why? They wanted it to be a real science.
Or as one commentator put it, "They suffered
from physics envy." Alright.
[pause]
Real science they felt dealt only with pure
number and objective measurement. This is
empiricism typified by say the Chicago schools.
Or else controversy, on the other side, it
dealt only with pure theory; abstract reasoning
from secure axioms, you know. This is the
idealism of the Austrian school.
But whatever it must be split from politics,
culture, values, society, everything must
stand on its own which meant of course it
must be self-regulating.
Obviously if you have no connection with the
political process or the social environment
of a culture or anything else, then you must
assume the market itself regulating.
Alright, what are the results of that?
So you have the myth of the self-regulating
market, one of the prime factors in creating
this current situation.
You had the divorce of justice and economics;
those were valuating questions.
[pause]
You had the divorce of the political and economic
order and hence a loss of any real understanding
of both orders. You cannot understand the
political order without understanding its
economic base. And a description of the political
order without that economic base simply makes,
doesn't describe anything.
At the same time the economic order is always
inscribed within a political order. And again
you cannot understand it as something separate
and apart because it doesn't exist that way.
Hence, what we had is a substitution of ideology
for real science. And that is indeed what
happens in the economic realm.
Their disputes can never be resolved because
they have no standard of truth by which to
arbitrate between the various schools.
[pause]
However, the most important thing to ask is:
does the theory work?
So I have a very busy chart up here. And reading
charts actually before you read any of the
actual text it's good to read the, just to
get the lay of the land, the graphics.
You'll notice up here that on this side of
the chart you see a lot of gray bands and
on this side of the chart is mainly white.
You see this red line, how erratic it is at
the beginning here and how much smoother it
is toward the end. And this blue line how
flat it is on the first part and then what
a steep slope it has, an exponential slope
at the end.
Well, those gray bands are recessions and
depressions.
[pause]
That red line is the change in GDP, the quarterly
change in E-GDP.
And that blue line is the growth of the economy
in absolute terms.
Notice here, this period here is a period
of pure free market ideology or as nearly
as pure as you can get it. And in that period
1900 to 1946 there were 12 contractions. These
12 contractions occurred almost every four
years; lasted 18 months; and had an average
decline in GDP approaching 7%.
But since that time we've had 11 contractions,
including the current one. They occur much
less frequently, every 6 years. They last
almost half as long, 10 months. And the average
decline is 1.5%.
So obviously there was something wrong with
this free market ideology. And that's why
people abandoned it because in this period
from 1853 to 1943 you had, we were in recession
or depression 40% of the time; 40%! Since
then we've been in recession even in-including
the current recession 15% of the time.
So which economy would you rather live in?
Yes, sir.
>>male in audience #3: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Except --
>>male in audience: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Yep.
>>John C. Medaille: Except the same thing
happened in England when it was a superpower.
As a matter of fact England's economy was
more, as it was a superpower, was more unstable
than the United States is. Yeah.
So it has to be something more than the super,
although superpower status certainly affects
it, it has to be something more than a superpower
status at work.
But in any case, the free market both in England
and the United States suffered from a chronic
failure of demand. As I said it was in recession
40%of the time, now since then it's been in
recession 15% of the time.
Why? What stabilized the economy? The wrong
thing.
Government became the big spender in the middle
that balanced supply and demand. Alright,
before the New Deal government, the federal
government budget was maybe two to 4% of GDP.
Since the New Deal it's varied from between
18 and 42% of GDP. That's quite a change.
So the free market ideology led to a big state
reality.
[pause]
And not just here, everywhere. There are no
historical exceptions to this. It was true
for every state; every advanced state is stasis.
[pause]
Of course the question now is: will this continue?
Have we kind of played this-this-this game
out?
Well, let's talk about how we get there.
Okay, here's where my computer skills get
really crude so, oh no, this starts at the
next slide, okay.
The, talk about justice and economics here.
Without distributive justice equity the economy
cannot reach equilibrium that it by itself.
It needs some non-economic help.
Now by equilibrium I mean that rough balance
between supply and demand without which people
will not, without-without the expectation
of equilibrium people will not bring goods
to market.
So equilibrium depends on equity, on justice.
It's a purely practical matter. Never mind
the moral arguments; as a purely practical
matter you've got to have some degree of equity
in the economy.
And I would argue that equity and equilibrium
are almost the same words and practically
the same thing.
Let's see how that actually works.
Here's where you have to cut me some slack.
My computer skills on drawing charts are little
bit crude, but.
Okay.
This line represents rising productivity which
is sort of a natural thing as technology improves
people get more skillful, etcetera, etcetera.
Alright and so in our economy through most
of our history we've had rising productivity
and at the same time we more or less had rising
wages. As productivity improved, wages improved.
Not always easily; sometimes industrial action;
sometimes a lot of social discord, but it
in general at the end of any 10 or 15 year
period productivity and wages came into line.
Then came the year 1973; a funny thing happened.
Productivity exploded in all categories of
labor. Wages flat lined.
[pause]
The median wage, the white male worker is
the same today as it was in 1973 and it never
moved up or down very much. As a matter of
fact, its 800 dollars lower today.
What was the response to this?
The first response was putting more family
members to work. Men, generally men, but women
entered the labor market.
In 1973 the median family was a one income
family. A couple of decades later it was a
two income family.
Yes sir.
>>voice in audience: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Yeah.
>>John C. Medaille: Yeah, yeah.
But that's the problem of addressing the cultural
and economic issues, you see.
It's not so much a matter of cause and effect,
it's a matter of things that happen that reinforced
each other. So a trend towards women's liberation
was also reinforced by the fact that it's
becoming more and more difficult to absorb
the goods and services on one income families.
It really is a mistake to separate the issues.
You never get a full picture.
However, since 1998 the family wage has flat
lined; the median wage.
So families workin' as hard as they ever did,
but they haven't received, a pay, their pay
has not kept up with the increase in goods
and services.
How did we absorb the output?
Consumer credit.
The people with money lent it to the people,
to the mass of people, usually at interest
rates of somewhere around 30%, to absorb the
excess goods and services.
This also led to the investor's dilemma. The
worker gets too little therefore the consumer
markets are undersupplied. The investor gets
too much; that is capital markets are oversupplied.
But this is contradictory because when you
narrow the consumer market you also narrow
true investment opportunities which depend
on the number of solvent consumers in the
market.
So what happened?
The investor turns to speculative instruments.
These are the CDO's, the MBS's, the CD's,
the synthetic CDO's, CDO's cubed, that sort
of thing. Which were pure finance instruments.
They didn't actually aid production which
is what finance is supposed to do.
So the investor got all that he wanted only
to find that that's not what he wanted at
all.
So I think here we have the conundrum of capitalism
expressed by G. K. Chesterton:
"Capitalism is contradictory as soon as it
is complete because it is dealing with the
mass of men in two opposite ways at once.
When most men are wage earners, it is more
and more difficult for most men to be customers.
For the capitalist is always trying to cut
down what his servant demands, and in doing
so he is cutting down what his customer can
spend. . . . He is wanting the same man to
be rich and poor at the same time."
So what is distributism?
Distributism is theory of the political economy
which deals with the crucial role of distributive
justice which is precisely the kind of justice
that the political economists, that the new
economists cut out of economics when they
invented their new science of economics.
Why? Because it can't be calculated. It can
only be judged. You can make a reasonable
judgment, but you can't make a calculation.
In their minds that meant it wasn't a science.
[pause]
So the distributivist, that's the only thing
that can make it scientific.
So it is a political economy. It assumes a
political framework and takes that political
social framework into account.
And as a political economy it measures success
of the economy by the support it gives to
families, communities, small business, small
farmers, etcetera.
[pause]
GDP or GNP is an insufficient measurement
of the economy. As a matter of fact, it's
deceptive because it may actually be a measure
of decline.
Take this example: society is collapsing;
leading to an increase in crime which means
we build more prisons. Prisons show up as
an increase in GDP, but it, is it really an
increase or is just an increase in costs?
[pause]
GDP treats negative expenditures as additions
to productivity. Alright, we have to deal
here with equity in two kinds.
Equity in rewards, the pay, and even under
standard economic theory, for the theory to
work rewards or returns to labor and capital
have to be normalized to each other. That
is neither by working nor by investing could
you earn very much more than one or the other.
They're sort of normalized to each other.
They're within a reasonable range.
As I say, that's a requirement of standard
theory.
There's also equity in property. And by property
we mean land or tools or skills; these are
all acquired as a property.
Now equity in property is very interesting.
Large concentrations of property distort the
market. You get monopolies, oligarchies, cartels.
They also distort the political process. You
get subsidies, tax breaks, bailouts, privileges.
And they are economically inefficient.
It's very funny Hayek, Friedrich Hayek has
this wonderful critique of socialism. And
he said point by point socialism doesn't work.
But if you look internal to a large multi-divisional
corporation you'll find that Hayek's critiques
apply point by point internal to the corporation.
The major real is, but many reasons but the
major reason I'll point out here is because
you have a large group selling to each other;
one division selling to each other; each division
using corporate services; there's no market.
There's no way to price them.
Yes, sir.
>>male in audience #4: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Um.
>>male in audience: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: I don't know because I
really don't know enough one about the-the
advertising market which is really what Google
is in. And two I-I think we're a little bit
early in the stage of the computer market
to understand how this is gonna play out.
It's definitely a special case, but I mean
it's a good question. I don't have the right
answer to it.
But I would also say that these things are
they're economically inefficient, but they're
very politically efficient. That is they learn
how to control governments; they learn how
to externalize costs; they learn how to get
subsidies.
But they also violate the vast number of firms
hypothesis and the standard theory every commodity
has to be for it to work. Every commodity
is supplied by a vast number of firms such
that no firm has any pricing power in the
market. They're all price takers rather than
price makers. That's not true when ownership's
concentrated.
And they displace small businesses. Wal-Mart
moved into a committee, community, all the
small shops close; so there's less opportunity
for people to become their own, their own
masters as it were.
Alright. Well distributed property then.
Property distributes economic freedom.
[pause]
And a person with their own property: land,
tools, skills is always in a much better bargaining
position and always has the option of going
out on his own.
Distributes political power. I mean it's,
I think it's useless to talk about democracy
when all the money's in one place.
Having spent my youth, my misspent youth as
a politician and been elected to office five
times, I understand the relationship between
money and politics.
It improves the wage because when people,
the wage is a bar, a negotiation. People who
have alternatives are in a better position
to negotiate; it's economically efficient.
It fulfills the vast number of firms hypothesis
and it requires less government. When there's
a better distribution of rewards, when people
are more self-reliant, they are less dependent
upon the state.
Yes, sir.
>>male in audience #5: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Ah, actually --
>>male in audience: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: That's an excellent question,
the, and would you hold 'till the end because
I have an example of just that; that addresses
that. Excellent question, though.
>>male in audience: [inaudible]
>>John C. Medaille: Okay.
People are more self-sufficient therefore
they're less dependent upon the government.
Now as soon as you talk about a better distribution
of property the first things that pops into
a lot of minds: SOCIALISM! [chuckles] Love,
there you go.
There's a fear of taking property from some
and giving it to others. But let me suggest,
I mean and indeed there are extreme cases
where that's necessary.
Let's not be shy about this.
Just take one example: Taiwan's Land to the
Tiller Program, where they took the land from
20 families and gave it to nearly half a million
families. And that led to such an expansion
of agriculture because it turns out people
work their own land better than they work
the master's land. That's just the way it
is.
That was the basis of that island's remarkable
movement from a feudal backwater to an industrial
powerhouse in just one generation.
Same thing with, by the way generally true
among the so-called Asian Tigers.
Here's another extreme case that worked the
opposite.
The TARP program. I mean these companies were
bankrupt and instead of buying them up and
distributing them to regional banks we gave
them a lot of money. We did the opposite.
The five biggest banks before this crash are
now even bigger. So --
[pause]
it-it turns out I think that distributing
property is not, mostly not about what government
does, but what about what it should stop doing.
Because government it turns out is the biggest
factor in property accumulation.
I mean there're some forms of property accumulation
which would not even be possible without a
legal forum and a government to support it
such as the limited liability corporation.
Now all of this may sound good to you, may
sound bad, doesn't matter.
When people are talking abstract principles
of economics or anything else dealing with
humans be very, very careful. Believe only
what you can see on the ground and working.
Whop.
[pause]
How do we get there?
Okay.
So let me talk about some real live examples.
First is the Mondragon Cooperative Corporation
of Spain. And this is a 50 year old, 60 year
old collection of cooperatives. There are
80,000 worker-owners and they do 25 billion
per annum in sales. And they do everything
from hunting, smooth bore hunting pieces to
electronic factories built to order. They
do finance; they do retail, mass retail; sixty
year history.
What-what's interesting about Mondragon is
that from its own resources they built a school
system, training institutes, a social safety
network, R & D facilities, even their own
university all without government help.
Oddly enough, it's the nearest thing to a
working libertarian system that we have in
captivity.
[pause]
Another example.
Believe what you can see.
This is in Emilia Romagna which is the area
around Bologna in Spain. And they have a 125
year history of worker cooperatives. And in
fact 35 to 40% of their GDP comes from worker
cooperatives.
They also have a different model from Mondragon.
Mondragon is, looks, its organization chart
would like a typical corporation.
But in Emilia Romagna they have a networked
organization. As a matter of fact, I think
it's more kinda like a, it's more, something
more in tune with those who work with the
Internet would-would understand because when
they cooperate on big jobs they joined temporary
alliances among these, all of these small
companies to work on big jobs; arbitrarily
big jobs.
And when that job, that order is over, then
they form different alliances to do different
things.
So it's interesting that the average wage
in Emilia Romagna is twice the average in
Italy. And they have, their standard of living
is among the highest in Europe.
Ok, believe what you can see.
And I think historically distributism goes
from success to success while capitalism goes
from bailout to bailout.
Alright, there's other examples: ESOP's, Cooperatives,
Mutual banks, insurance companies, could do
this one all day.
[pause]
There we go.
Alright, so that brings me to the book and
my publisher said I had to push the book.
Let me summarize some things.
[pause]
Man is both an individual and a social being.
Current economic theories treat him either
as a pure individual in which we get certain
forms of libertarianism not all of them, or
as a pure social entity which we get socialism
and communism.
Both are incorrect because they start with
an incorrect understanding of man. Human freedom
is both personal and social, okay.
[pause]
Market freedom then provides the material
base for both personal and social freedom.
In other words this market freedom is not
just an abstract entity it has a practical
purpose. We want it for a reason. And it has
both social and individual aspects. Okay?
That's why merely taking an individual aspect
like Jay Gould's free use of his railroad
is not sufficient to supply a free market.
[pause]
Material freedom is routed in distributed
property of some kind or another.
Political freedom works best with free, self-reliant
people in strong communities. And these strong
communities must have a strong economic base.
Material and political freedom are necessary
for market freedom.
[pause]
In the end, I think the task is to make political
economy accessible to a wide audience and
that's why I wrote this book.
My first book was a textbook; did very well;
I was very proud of it; got very nice academic
reviews, okay.
But let's say textbook, textbooks tend to
be assigned reading.
The, but I did want to write something that
was accessible to the general public, because
I think without some knowledge of political
economy there's no way out of our current
problems.
And I wanted to apply it to our present problems.
I wanted to apply it to the questions involving
taxes or trade or deficits or that health
care since we've just had such a wonderful
two-year fact free debate.
[laughter]
And I wanted to do this without the normal
economic jargon that I think puts people off.
[chuckles]
I talked to somebody yesterday. She said,
"You know reading economics" reminded her
of reading Sartre's Nausea. And Sartre's Nausea
and everything, so everything the protagonist
touched it kind of just melted away and it-it
the whole feeling made him nauseous and she
said, "Well, reading economics everything
is mushy in that same way," and it just made
her nauseous.
So I'm hoping to write a book that overcomes
economic nausea.
[pause]
Okay, let me suggest something. There are
no solutions to our current problems under
the current institutional arrangements. I
think we've played this string out.
We have 15 million unemployed by the most
optimistic estimates, the U3 estimate. We
have 200,000 new workers that come on stream
each month. There is no combination of industries
that can conceivably grow under current institutional
arrangements to absorb that workforce.
[pause]
Reform is mandatory; collapse is optional.
We will either have collapse and then reform
or we will have reform and avoid collapse.
So the two options for reform: dictatorship
is always one 'cause there's always somebody
with all the answers or whether he has all
the answers or not he managed to get all the
armies; so, which is in the world that often
equates to having all the answers.
But I think the other option is property;
a better understanding of property; by the
way, a discussion that's almost disappeared
from the textbooks.
And, that's all I have.
I thank you all for coming.
[applause]
Yes sir.
>>male in audience #6: Going back to, going
back to my original question before which
how do you handle the case of things that
can only either be manufactured at scale or
for things or for just generally non-commodity
items?
>>John C. Medaille: Oh yeah.
Well I think that's the-the beauty of the
thing is that there's not one form of ownership;
there's not one form of organization. And
it can be scales any size. That was my point
in the Mondragon example.
If you had, it was an American corporation
that would be around 125th, 150th largest
in the United States. So I mean it's scalable
to any arbitrary size.
>>male in audience: So I mean is this more
just encouraging the idea of employee-owned
cooperatives of, in any particular business?
>>John C. Medaille: I, yeah. Now remember
that's one of the, that's one of the options.
That's one of the options.
The, a lot of tech companies, and I think
this may be true of Google they-they gave
employees a wonderful sense of ownership through
stock options and through various management
techniques so people really felt that they
owned the space they were working in.
The, I've noted, by the way, that there's
a company in Seattle that used to do that,
the company will remain nameless. But now
I think they've outsourced so much of their
work like the mailroom they went, they sent
to SEM and the printing shop they sent to
Xerox and the-the food service they sent to
some company and now they mostly hire temps.
And I think, I think it shows up in their
products. But what do I know? Except for that,
except for that my computer from that company
froze up this morning just when I needed it.
[chuckles]
[laughter]
>>male in audience #6: This other question
--
>>John C. Medaille: Yeah.
>>male in audience: what happens if in the
same market --
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: or the same society distibu-distributive
portion and current capitalists --
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: are entities? Wouldn't
that be but, how do they coexist? Because
the two examples you gave are from Europe
--
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: different social, different-different
heritage, I would say.
>>John C. Medaille: Yes, yes.
>>male in audience: I would give for example.
I used to have a life insurance policy with
a mutual life insurance --
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: and they decided that
it's not good for them any longer.
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: so they gave me --
>>John C. Medaille: Big mutual --
>>male in audience: 1800 dollars and we said
back now they're converting the mutual life
insurance into a stock company and it's no
longer mutual.
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: So you, how would you
protect, suppose this is actually better,
the new form is better. But it has to, you
can't switch everything at once. There'll
be a time when it will be --
>>John C. Medaille: Yes, yes.
>>male in audience: two systems in-in-in the
same society. What will happen then?
>>John C. Medaille: Yeah.
Well I mean are you, you've shown me examples
in Europe, but I could have cited examples
in the United States.
One very good book or that I would recommend
is Jack Stack's A Stake in the Outcome about
Springfield Remanufacturing Company. And that's
just a superb, those who are interested in
the management questions, because this enlightens
management as well are advised to read that
book.
The problem you-you raised here of demutualization
depends on the legal framework because in
a mutual the policy holders are supposed to
be the owners, the policy holders are supposed
to be the owners. However, again whether they
have any real power depends on the charter
and the legal framework involved.
So, but there's still lots of good mutual
insurance companies like Northwest Mutual
Life, for example, which has always been a
mutual company.
I think Mutual of Omaha is another and they're
very successful.
Yeah.
So as far as coexisting, they do coexist.
But I think the law right now and the big
canons of the law are on one side. However,
that's gonna change because everything's gonna
change. The question how much influence and
in what direction will you affect the change?
[pause]
>>male in audience: Okay. I have a follow
up question --
>>John C. Medaille: Yes, sir.
>>male in audience: I'm interested in human
nature. There are some systems that are very
nice --
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: in theory but we fail
--
>>John C. Medaille: Absolutely.
>>male in audience: --because it negates human
nature.
>>John C. Medaille: Absolutely.
>>male in audience: Communism for example.
>>John C. Medaille: Pardon.
>>male in audience: Comminism.
>>>John C. Medaille: Yes. Or capitalism.
>>male in audience: That's another. I will
give, stick with communism.
>>John C. Medaille: Okay. Your choice. [laughs]
[laughter]
>>male in audience: Now suppose you, suppose,
one of the things with-with-with hopefully
good capitalism is if you have very good idea
and you happen to have a good lawyer on your
side, you may become very successful because
you really have the best idea, you have technology,
you protect yourself, and you begin to become
as successful as you wish, unless you get
taxed to death. But it's a separate thing.
But you can become successful. It means that
you accumulate wealth --
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: because you deserve to
accumulate wealth.
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum, um-hum.
>>male in audience: It will be something new.
>>John C. Medaille: Um-hum.
>>male in audience: Something better.
>>male in audience: Would that be possible
at all under distributive, in a distributive
system?
>>John C. Medaille: Well I'm sure, yes it
is because there're people who-who do it.
However, it depends on what you mean by accumulating
wealth. If you mean that one man should have
50 billion dollars that he cannot possibly
spend; Aristotle recommended in those cases,
and Aristotle was no Communist by any means,
Aristotle recommended that a person that rich
ought to be exiled as a danger to the body
politic.
And I only bring that up to say that this
is not a new question and has been discussed
a while.
People ought to earn their contribution to
production, whatever that contribution is.
But when you find out that it's really a contribution
protected by a government monopoly through
patent, I'm not so sure then if that the government
then in protecting the monopoly doesn't have
some rights to talk about the distribution.
Now if you wanna get government out of it
and say, "Government, we're not enforcing
patent," then we'll how much he accumulates.
The, but if the government's in it, you can't
argue both ways. You can't argue, "Government
defend my accumulation," and "Government say
out of my accumulation." You gotta choose
one or the other.
[pause]
Okay.
Well you're very kind and you're very patient.
And I do thank you for coming.
>>voice in audience: Thank you very much.
[applause]